come and see what everyone's talking
about Jesus was his messenger bismillah
al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum we greet
you with the best of greetings are
secreting a peace peace be with you you
are here to learn that's why you turn on
to the Dean show or you were just
flickering through the channels and you
heard Islam and Muslims you thought
something's about to blow up and you got
excited hold on that's not the case we
are here try to help you develop a
better understanding so sit tight we're
going to be right back with dr. Gerald
Dirk's Christian scholar graduate from
the Harvard Divinity School and we're
going to be talking about Jesus peace be
upon him was Jesus a Christian or was
Jesus doing Islam as a Muslim when we
come back here on the Dean show don't go
nowhere this is the theme the theme this
is the thing
this is within you know this is the
things this is the Salam alaikum well I
alaikum Salaam please be with you and
with you brother now you know I started
off the program to do stupid before that
you know I mentioned things blowing up
you know there's some hype out that
people are trying to associate Islam
with terrorism and Islam terrifying
people it's like the boogeyman is coming
to get you you as a Christian you did
your homework is this far from the truth
or did you already miss something here
maybe you gonna have to backtrack talk
to us no I is obviously far from the
truth there are a few a handful of
people who are self proclaimed Muslims
yeah who offer up a violent ideology
that is a total perversion of Islam the
same thing however can be said for
Judaism or Christianity or for any of
the world's religions there are always
going to be people who try to cloak
their own geo political or nationalistic
ambitions under a mantle of religion and
no grab whichever religion is handy you
know whether it's Islam or Christianity
or Judaism or Hinduism or what have you
but no Islam is not a religion of
terrorism it's not a religion that
condones terrorism some might say and
you've probably heard this that all
terrorists aren't Muslim but it seems
like all Muslims are terrorists well
first of all obviously all Muslims are
not terrorists but it's also the case
that not all terrorists are Muslims yes
we had a case not long ago in Wichita
Kansas where a doctor who is performing
late-term abortions was murdered as he
was standing in his church yeah who
murdered him a
right wing christian ideo log yeah who
believed he was saving the lives of
unborn children and so he murdered the
doctor standing in his church this would
be an example of a Christian terrorist
yes now Christianity certainly does not
condone the sort of behavior that this
murderer engaged but this person claimed
to be doing it in the name of
Christianity a number of years ago in
Hebron in Palestine we had a Jew who
went into the mosque at Hebron and
started shooting Muslims as they pray
obviously this does not represent
Judaism yes but this person was a Jew
and what he was doing he was doing in
the name of Judaism yeah you know but
we're going to find these sorts of
things in every religion so it's not
fair that you want to single out a few
crackpots you know a few bad apples in
every Bunch as they say there are you
had the Unabomber if you look at
Columbine shooting have you know
terrorists by the tons out there but so
we want to separate Islam which is a
perfect system from the crater and what
some you know crazy people might do
let's not put those together anisur say
yeah even though those crazy people may
be trying to justify what they're doing
by some perverted notion of Islam yeah
you know that's no more Islam than James
Jones or David Koresh a representative
of Christianity one more point before we
get into it because they'll say and I've
heard this and it's a shame they say
well why aren't Muslims condemning this
and we're condemning it here on this
show we've done it so many times because
people want to revisit 911 and we know
it's LOM Muslims died in 911 absolutely
in fact it is proportionately large
number of the victims of the Twin Towers
and I'm not talking about the hijackers
I'm talking about people who work to the
twin towers where Muslims you know it
was a higher percentage than there are
Muslims of the population of the United
States who worked in the toy Twin Towers
and were killed there now you raise an
interesting point which is people said
well why aren't
you know mainstream Muslims standing up
and condemning these attacks the answer
is we are and we're doing it
consistently but the problem is that a
Muslim standing up and condemning
terrorism that doesn't sell a newspaper
yes that doesn't drive up the ratings
and some top televisions not good for
business huh no it's not good for
business and it's not going to cover the
media will not cover it yeah you know
but all of the major Muslim
organizations in this country which I'm
aware have systematically condemned
terrorism systematically spoken out
against it you know whether it's the
Islamic Society of North America or the
Islamic circle of north america or the
Muslim American Society you know
everyone has spoken up but the press
doesn't cover it and we're doing it
again here Aladin show and you're
available for CNN Fox if anybody wants
to bring you on on their mainstream
channel I'll be glad to condemn
terrorism definitely and we are doing it
again so but let's get in now to our
main topic Christianity Islam which of
these ways of life which of these
religions did Jesus Christ practice
teach preach well obviously it wasn't
Christianity because Christianity didn't
exist at least by name at the time of
Jesus we're told in the book of Acts in
the New Testament that the first people
to be called Christians arose in Antioch
some years after the end of Jesus is a
personal ministry here on earth no Jesus
was a Muslim we're told on Muslim well
now let's look at what word means first
let's look at what the word means Islam
means surrender and in any religious
context it means surrender or submission
to God to God to God to the one guy
right ok Muslim is simply a very
Anton the word Islam it means one who
submits or one who surrenders again used
in a religious context it's one who
submits two or surrenders to god that's
what Muslim means now when we look at
that definition obviously cause to make
sense now yeah jesus was a Muslim yeah
in that sense of the word he was a
submitter to God yes now what is
Christian when you take to do the same
thing and take if someone says well no
no Christianity means to submit to God
canaan connecticut it what is
christianity now on Christianity does it
you can't derive that from the word
crazy you can't know you can give it
some kind of interpretation to say yeah
that's what it being buyer that's not
what it well translates to know it's
doesn't translate to that Christianity
obviously from the word Christ Christ is
the Christos the greek form of the
hebrew word mafia or Messiah which in
english means anointed yeah so that mean
that's the etymology of the word okay so
let's back it up so it goes from the
Hebrew Messiah mm-hmm Masha to Greek
Christo's Christo's translated so
Messiah translated to Greek crystals
yeah and then you got what Christ Christ
what are you cutting off the stones at
the end you're just shortening the word
so you have Christ and those who follow
Christ they came up with Christians the
Christ followers well in Antioch they
did in Antioch yo okay so then how did
people well you know what we're going to
take a break in this is really getting
exciting I'll be right back with more of
dr. Gerald Dirk's here on the disha I am
not afraid to stand alone if Eliza
I am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if a las vacas i
am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if a las vacas I i
am not afraid to stay
back here on the Dean show with dr.
Gerald Dirk's you finished seminary
school you have a divinity degree from
the Harvard University so we're not
talking to as I always say this a car
mechanic we're talking to a christian i
like call your Christian scholar because
we got to face it you know more about
the Bible than probably ninety five
percent of the Christian world well let
me know okay you don't even read the
Bible wow that's true okay so most
Christians who never read the entire
body yes but now don't not coming a
scholar coming a student gets a more
accurate term okay now tell us dr.
Gerald Dirk's we're going to back it up
we'll even go back to Moses his time
because many people and we are trying to
really enlighten people to these facts
this is not fiction so people attribute
Moses to being a follower of Judaism is
this true was he following the religion
of Judaism well Moses also was obviously
someone who submitted to God a Muslim
well in that sense of the word yes he
was a Muslim he was someone who
submitted to God now if we look at the
origins of the word Judaism yes you know
really it begins with Judah Judah who
was one of the 12 sons of Jacob so Jacob
that's one of his sons Judah okay so I
mean here's the origins of the word but
really what we call Judaism today yes
doesn't really begin until around the
Year 400 BCE when Ezra and men of the
great assembly as we're returning from
the Babylonian captivity returning to
Palestine when they began to put
together the great assembly and begin to
write apparently some of the old
testament at least according to the
jewish talmud yes and this is really the
origins
of Judaism as we know it today before
that time we might talk about the
religion of the Israelites and that
might make more sense talk to us about
that please in terms of what now so the
religion of the Israelites were they
ones that the children of Israel yes of
course so so that was during the time of
Moses then well this is a division i
would make okay you know that I see
Judaism really beginning at the time of
Ezra and the men of the great assembly
but even then we have different branches
of Judaism yet they were going on and
Judaism that we have today rabbinic
Judaism really is something that begins
to take hold and develop after the
destruction of the temple in the year 70
siiii mm-hmm so this is around is this
after again the time of moat this is
definitely after the time of Moses oh
yes so if he was too if you were to
bring him back to life right now would
he be practicing Judaism Christianity or
Islam well obviously he's a Muslim
ominous he's going to practice his love
but by definition if we had all these
terms now we you just described where
Judaism come from from from the tribe of
from the Judah you have Judaism and then
you gave the history then you have
Christianity from Christ this is named
after a person and then persons and then
you have Islam which cause a person to
acquire peace by submitting like you
said submitting your will to the will of
the One God so I mean just as a layman I
know that Moses he was calling people to
that he was doing that yes so we had a
multiple choice what I mean well I think
if we had a multiple choice what we'd
have to say is that Moses would probably
recognize elements in all three
religions uh-huh you know but there
would be elements within Judaism he
certainly wouldn't recognize okay that
came into being long after his time
certainly elements and Christianity that
he would not recognize this God having a
son or the Trinity or any of these
things did he preach teacher or or or
give forewarning about this coming no no
no okay this is very interesting it's
enlightening and that's we're trying to
do it in
lighten the hearts and minds of the
people now bringing it back to Jesus
peace be upon him so the main question
here is was Jesus peace be upon him was
he practicing Christianity or Islam and
if you can just continue from where well
again Christianity didn't exist even by
name yeah at the time of Jesus you know
us if we want to look at the origins of
Christianity to a great extent we have
to look at Paul of Tarsus yeah as the
person who originated Christianity much
more so than one would look at Jesus so
is the safe to say okay in the Arabic
it's Islam yes but now if you were
speaking Aramaic just like you and
correct me you're our teacher here today
the language of Jesus was it Aramaic yes
it would have been Aramaic so when we
look and we dig how he called on God the
Creator because he didn't speak English
he would say aloha and Aramaic is it
true well even even we look at Hebrew
yes you know we have in the Old
Testament we have the words Elohim and
el Elohim these are the words typically
translated as God in most English
versions of the Old Testament and these
words are linguistically similar
comparable to the Arabic word Allah yes
no Hebrew and Arabic or sister languages
this is a Semitic language group and
we're told that the word Allah by eamonn
Abbas simply means a lot in other words
Allah is a contraction for out Allah and
Allah literally translated is the God
the God period the one guy yeah now
Elohim in Hebrew again the gods plural
but that's a plural of respect mm-hmm
now let's take a little deeper if I
spell out a lot in Arabic letters is al
aslam Aleph la
ha now people listening remember these
letters Aleph la Aleph la ha that's a la
now if I spell el Elohim in Hebrew
letters I spell it Aleph LOM Aleph LOM
ha you're mean we have this good and
mean at the end of LOL eloheem otherwise
the Spelling's identical what about this
Yahweh Yahweh yeah yeah is this can we
could we say that this is the same a law
or what would what would you give and
how would you translate this the meaning
of this Yahweh now biblical scholars
have some debate amongst themselves yeah
as to the proper translation of Yahweh
I've heard it somehow transit as the
everliving God ha i am that i am I
caused to be what I caused to be I mean
these are all sort of translations have
been offered by one or another yeah
biblical scholar but certainly yeah yeah
way is the is God yeah you know the
Quran tells us you know call upon Allah
or call upon a rock man the
compassionate by whatever name you call
upon him it is well you know so yes
Yahweh yeah Elohim Allah God so as long
as we're not now mixing up the Creator
with his creation and forming a mental
image a picture having got turned into a
man and then he overhears a cat oh and
oh he's a monkey or anything on the
creation that is where we draw to my
said no that can't be the crater
absolutely but we don't draw the line in
terms of language language okay you know
if you have your Greek you're going to
see fails if your Latin you're going to
say dais yeah you know so it's the
concept here that we're really the
attributes of God and how he defines
himself that we go by tell tell it we're
going to take a break and we
back with more god what a hot with dr.
Joe Dirt's he is the leading coming to
the truth requires two things that
requires deep thinking that you've
already done but it requires another
step and that's courage if you have the
truth but you don't have courage you
won't stand up for the truth and that's
as good as standing up for falsehood I
would say this thing that you just told
me it's not in the scripture and they
would say a marginal note added by
scribe yeah okay we know that and I'd be
thinking if you know this is not the
Bible why are you preaching it as if
it's gospel truth that's from hunger
I started out actually in high school I
was a born again Christian I accepted
Christ as my Lord and Savior as we used
to say and I became very committed as an
evangelical Christian and I went off to
moody bible institute for call it
because a fundamentalist bible college
after that I went to Wheaton College
which is a liberal arts college if it's
Billy Graham's alma mater it's in heaven
Jellicle school so I had very solid
evangelical Christian commitments and
eventually I got a seminary degree and I
was a pastor of a Baptist Church for a
year but gradually for a large number of
reasons I started to question some of
the assumptions that I had about the
faith for a long time I thought that the
Bible was inspired and inerrant that
there were no mistakes in the Bible but
as I engaged in historical research on
the Bible as I was getting my PhD in New
Testament studies at Princeton
Theological Seminary I started finding
mistakes in the Bible and this this cut
away at my assumptions that the Bible
was an errand and then I started
questioning other parts of my faith is
Jesus really divine is a really a
Trinity today we are talking about
answering the question Jesus peace be
upon him who was beloved to our hearts
and we do this these type of programs
because we want to share because we care
and there's some misinformation about
many of God's messengers and God
Almighty sent the last and final
revelation the last Testament the Koran
the verbatim word of God to clear these
things up so we're just trying to share
and give a different perspective and all
we ask is people that they have an open
heart and open mind and consider tell us
now this concept of acquiring piece of
submitting yourself to the one god so if
you were to take that into the hebrew
language Aramaic language french
language it's that concept that's the
main thing that you submit and surrender
your will to the will of the creator
absolutely it will still get hung up on
a word and a word people get hung up on
ergo contagious yeah you know whether
you say Allah or whether you say God or
whether you say Yahweh you know we're
talking about the same thing
you know if you're German you say good
instead of God same thing you know and
it's not let differences in languages
drive us apart what we are talking about
is the one and only deity yes so when we
say the one and only deity when we
describe his attributes I feel as most
of us do that these connect with the
human being that he is without beginning
without end that he is not like his
creation that he is independent of all
but we're all dependent on him we are
all very dependent upon yeah so is this
also something that all the messengers
that we see I mean you know the Bible
you know back and forth is this what we
see if anyone who is sincerely looking
to do God's will if they even study as
being a Christian or a Jew and they
study it will they come to the same
realization as most of us have that you
know Islam is definitely indeed in the
Bible and it's there as a message was
teach by all the prophets taught by
other prophets sure I think anyone who
reads the Bible with an open mind and
does a little digging will find that the
answer and the answer is that there is
one God and that we as God's creation
are called upon to submit to him to
surrender to him and that are one God is
a very much a personal God yes as a God
who offers us love offers his compassion
offers us mercy when we fail he offers
us forgiveness if we turn to him with
repentance in our heart and the effort
to change our ways many attributes of
God and by the way another pitfall of
language one that we can't avoid we both
have here today refer to God with the
masculine pronoun yes and obviously God
you know we can't categorize according
to masculine or feminine pronouns etc
this is just simply the convention
the English language that we use the
masculine pronoun but the attributes of
God some are masculine in nature some
are feminine in nature dr. Jill Dirk's
thank you very much if people want to
invite you to come and to give a talk a
lecture a seminar how can people get a
hold of you they can reach me at my
website which is Dirk's online books com
it's Dirk's online books that's all one
word calm thank you very much maybe I
did the Creator love reward you for
being with us thank you thank you and we
hope that you got to benefit from
another episode of the Dean show the
question was raised and the question was
answered Jesus peace be upon him he did
islam Moses did islam abraham did islam
what it's not yes they all sought peace
from the owner of peace they submitted
themselves humbly to the one God the one
who created you mean who created man
woman but he's not a man or woman it's
the one guy the one that has given us so
much the one that we should be getting
grateful for thankful to and if you like
what we had to say here continue to tune
in every week you can also call the
number on the screen 1 866 to islam to
learn more and we'll see you next time
here on the DS show until that peace be
unto you is the Linden one of the
beautiful things about our religion of
Islam is the emphasis on direct ritual
and prayer that God directly there is no
intermediary the lights will go on after
the party and the party will end it's
very simple and very clear there are no
superstitious rituals no strange
incantations and time is running out and
you might not make it till tomorrow and
this is something that we need to think
of
no speech is better than to do that
would call people to Allah and to do
there were no speeches better no nothing
is better than that is it true that if
one person I'm the Allah giving you an
ability to guide someone for the lost
permission the craters permission that
is better than everything in this world
but in the whole world and everything
that's in it in another narration it's
better than the best of wealth but if we
really felt that Eddie would we not be
getting out getting done and this is
something that we encourage all the msas
all the dowel organizations the mustards
forget this we want to threaten or we
give these to the non melissa's for free
for free for free one-hour brothers it's
cold Italy everybody sleep in I arise
and ask a lot of thinking may Omar you
see all are you know all the sins I do I
turn to you to figure my Seng tomorrow
I'm you seen for slave you're my love
alone I'm the one runs away all the
guide me